on this episode we talk peach we talk
interruption and value and we talk New
Year's resolutions
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 174 of the ask gary vee
show a little salty I'm supposed to be
recording my audio book right now there
was some calendar mix-up not sure I
haven't gotten to the bottom of it just
yet it doesn't really matter
spilled milk not interested in dealing
with it
moving forward taping the show mmm you
actually you'll see the moment where I
found out there was a mixup as d-roc is
doing daily vol 4 super meta is what it
is
Tyler's trying to forget my phone there
do a little snapchat while we're doing
it India looks super ready let's just uh
let's just do it I'm ready okay MJG asks
do you set personal and business goals
for new year if so how do you stay focus
throughout the year I do not I have one
business goal which is to buy the New
York Jets really my business goal there
is to have the game of trying to buy the
Jets I do set personal goals they come
at hawk you know I started taking care
of my health
in July not in January so I don't I
understand why people do the Fresh Start
makes sense whatever works for you I
keep myself in check by talking to
myself often I probably communicate with
myself more than most people it's not
like hey Gary hey Gary any kind of weird
kind of like or silly or interesting
stuff it's just um I think a lot I
ponder a lot I I check myself if I'm
happy or focused or what have you so I
don't do anything in the New Year that's
um though I tend to do new things in a
new year so you know I'm sure this
snapchat hustle has a little bit to do
with the new year but um no I do not
Kevin asks you are incredibly passionate
about snapchat now snapchats been around
a few years why now what's changed Kevin
I've done this a lot I did this with
Instagram as well I I only get really
loud in my career when I think things
hit that moment when were just a year
away from mainstream I'm in love with
the moment when something's much bigger
than people realize
mainstream right before I went on to do
this show right now I just retweeted
that the White House went on snapchat
which I think has always been a symbolic
kind of thing many of other things I I
have had a good understanding of
consumer behavior a website in 1996
email marketing in 97 Google AdWords
starting a YouTube show you know people
are just right I bet you you could
Google right now like why starting a
YouTube shows a good idea I did that ten
years ago Twitter changed the course of
my career I wrote a book called crush it
that basically speaks about everything
that's going on right now on YouTube and
vine and Instagram and snapchat
the reason I'm passion now is even
though two years ago I was like ooh this
snapchat thing is gonna win the numbers
are there this is the moment right now
where I see that window of 12 to 18
months to really land grab at scale
before the whole market comes along and
tries to do the same I believe that
that's why so many of the people
watching the show and watching my
content are gonna win many people that
were already paying attention to me
because of what I did on YouTube focused
on Twitter and Facebook pages and were
successful because I didn't yell about
Instagram as much because I was very
head down I'm Boehner that was probably
the one it happened so fast
it didn't be like it happened so fast it
didn't even you know it's funny if I I
know you asked me right before we went
on you want to do something about peach
I do it's the real like Instagram
happens so fast I don't even have time
to like let it go mainstream and then
talk about it so so why now cuz it's the
moment my moment and my moment is
defined as the attention graph moment
which is the moment one year before
something goes completely mainstream
where I think some
big enough to really land grab and I'm
not guessing and I'm not wasting my time
which is what a lot of people ask me
they're like how do you not waste your
time easy because I'm tasting things
like peach and musically but I'm not all
in it's funny a lot of you were like why
she said I hear a lot of people saying
is snapchat paying Gary Oh Gary
investing and snapchat year ago guys I
care about my personal brand and being
right more than anything more than
anything in the world in the woods how I
will make all my might there's no
transaction that will trump me being
this right historically show me that
ghost
Stefan grab me the ghost I mean what
episode was this ghost on like a hundred
episodes ago like this isn't like today
this isn't like like this has been
watching carefully calculating what do
you think all this is like by accident
you think I got lucky you think it's
like you think it's this you think I'm
throwing random [ __ ] on the table you
think I'm predicting peach is gonna be
number one and then hoping three years
for two no it is an understanding it is
a talent of understanding when things
are on the dawn of complete Main Street
allottee and so I'm loud right now
because I'm gonna end up being right
geez some serious silence song right
I like deep songs India yeah you'd be
surprised right you think of me as like
a bubble pop like sugar pop mainstream
right yeah exactly
oh yeah Miley is way deeper than you
think yeah deeper than you think but I
like deep songs that you knew culture
nerds believe is deep - yeah that's
anybody who like really listens to them
you like like people that hate when
things sell out you know and you're like
the person that hates when things sell
out nice you're right
I agree with that actually I do know
that about you I was trying to peg you
that was unfair of me you're a super
cell Oh check
Yeah right
Arif ass when I'm at the office even
though I have a meeting I feel guilty
about leaving my team in the office I'm
scared if my team thinks that the boss
is always playing having fun and always
taking a long break at lunch any advice
easy Earth results like if you're
playing around and having a coffee with
this person and networking with that
person or sitting courtside at a Knicks
game and you aren't working but you
bring somebody and you make a 10 million
dollar deal it's called [ __ ]
results you know funny thing squashes
all the boss doesn't do anything results
so you know how to deal with it it's um
you know it's uh its first you know it's
funny its first rapping you know I grew
up in a world that my dad taught me and
I executed in the first 10 years of my
career that was predicated on being at
the store meant you were bringing value
and like and so I get it I actually get
that question hardcore I barely ever
left Wine Library in the first 10 years
of my career I was in the same goddamn
place like every day Monday through
Saturday every single day for like 10
years from 9th like I was super like
locatable like you know it was a so I
get it and you know what it was a
mistake I should have took more trips to
wine country I should have knocked up
more doors and done b2b and sold hundred
cases at a pop to corporations in New
Jersey I should have got out and about
and so you know if you're a kind of boss
that goes to off sites and then thinking
and parties at night and your business
goes down well then people feel like you
didn't deliver and so you can get away
with anything
if you drive results I don't think
anybody at Vayner questions me being
around or not being around because of
the results and so that's it I mean you
know the score is the score you know you
know it doesn't matter how you get there
cheating doing the wrong things the
moral compass matters but if you're able
to do things on the up-and-up
then the score is the score a TAS is it
a beautiful interruption in your
consumers day a good thing or should it
be seamless
excuse me
like a beautiful interruption is it if
it interrupts you but it's enjoyable is
it good or should everything be seamless
it's it's good because you said
something very interesting there India
in your interpretation you said the word
enjoyable guys there's only value
there's not it the seamless and
interruption isn't the game its value if
if one perceives it as valuable then
then it's a win if the greatest looking
girl and the girl that Tyler loves the
most in the world jumped into this
office while he was in the middle of
something and kissed him on the lips he
would be happy with that interruption on
the other hand if I punched him in his
face and broke his tooth that would be a
bad interruption that didn't bring him
value the other one did its value it's
not interruption it's not seamless it's
not these marketing jargon terms its
value and so if something you said
enjoyable enjoyable as a value and so
its value so if you're able to bring
value if if somebody runs three minutes
late to a meeting because you block the
road on the way to their meeting which
is bad time is the asset I always say
but if they valued what happened in
those three minutes more than the three
minutes they lost in a meeting for
example if that Street was littered with
rare jet jerseys and they were free and
I got them I'd be okay with being three
minutes late because I value that more
if that if that Street was littered with
Misha performing a five minute play on
the street I value that more than being
three minutes late if it was Barack
asking me a stupid question I'd be upset
even though I loved dealloc the
execution of that wasn't as good
so it's the answer is yes I think to the
question which is you can interrupt
people all day long you know when I talk
about marketing I talk about value much
more than seamless or interruption that
trumps everything
and it's perceived value by that
individual it's not what you as a
business think is valuable everybody's
gonna love this because you want them to
love it because you want to sell it to
them
and some people value something that
other people don't so that's just how
that works out the market decides it's a
very weird vibe five five five five
because everybody knows because d-roc
doesn't do a good job editing the daily
bee and exposes things like my room
number and my passcode in one episode
yes it was
somebody somebody DM me it it was you
didn't know about it cuz I want to hurt
your feelings but that's why everybody
knows some thrill to put it out on this
0:04 and the askgaryvee show i was just
saying it's a weird mood show make sense
don't judge people your name is India no
he probably isn't from America India
it's not just an American world and then
there's other people from the world okay
well Dennis it's cool maybe his parents
are hippies Dennis Dennis asks what do
you think of the new emerging social
media peach a fad or something
revolutionary I have no idea but I do
know this Dom who created who's who him
and his team created vine is an
extremely talented product person I've
been flirting with it I've been tasting
the peach a little bit and you like that
one's that fun I know how you roll that
was really you know it's so weird I
literally did that just for you there
was a one audience value prop statement
and I'm not ready to to say that it's
gonna be here forever this and that
clearly it's a beautiful product clearly
the early tech nerds have fallen in love
with it and are playing with it
it's got my attention but very little
right now because I'm in a complete
snapchat storm there's only so many
hours in the day but I'm gonna flirt
with it over the next couple of weeks
months watch consumer behavior see if
it's sticky there's been plenty of apps
that come out in the tech world with
enormous fanfare that
have 2069 so it's gonna be Clark which
is something a lot of you don't remember
from 2008
this is gonna be daily booth which AJ
and I thought was gonna be the biggest
thing ever big call by AJ was right
basically became Instagram but it didn't
win ORS it'll become Instagram or
snapchat so I don't know I'm excited
bout I think chat chat apps still have a
lot of room especially something like
this but you know path had a lot of
users it was a really investor I believe
in that product I was revolutionary but
it's not here anymore
didn't get it fully win and so you know
it's an exciting thing I like watching
new trends I do think Stefan you should
edit in the corner here while I'm
talking about peach if I gotta soon
there's a video on YouTube already of
like this is what peach looks like and
things of that nature so I guess you can
edit that or rip it I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah that's it so that's by the way to
bring value in this show and not just
like to bring real value in the show
that's what I tend to do I tend to
parallel path I'm always using and
squeezing the orange to my hardest on
the things that I think have crossed
over the hill and have become mainstream
items for me and I believe in you know
Instagram Facebook now snapchat right
that's what I'm doing over here and
there's always a three to twelve percent
of my energies being deployed to the
music leaves and the peaches and the
kicks of the world to just keep an eye
because by the way that's what I was
doing with snapchat like I was watching
I've been watching all along like you
know I've been watching watching I'm
still watching Pinterest four years
later now - like when is that moment
gonna cross over that it's not just
heavy female shopping aspirational isn't
gonna cross over mail isn't gonna cross
over for marketers where I can put
infographics right LinkedIn I was
watching it then that content thing
happened and influencers a year and a
half ago and I jumped then they diluted
it with pulse and I jumped back it's a
marketplace of attention my friends
there is no you know like this is what I
said six years ago I don't give a [ __ ]
what I said six years ago was six years
ago I don't care what I said six minutes
ago it is a living and
reading marketplace of attention that I
execute against that's why I have
success because I've been good at
judging the right things to bet on with
my time and energy and because I take
the time to listen and watch consumers
on it and then cultivate a content
strategy that actually brings people
value for the attention that they deploy
against me and that was a good way to
wrap up the show because it took all the
things in the show in one little rant at
the end question of the day question of
the day
what's your early read on peach have you
even heard of it prior to this episode
and if not how quickly did you download
it you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]